tricky though
come on Danielle don't quit on me now
you [ __ ] [ __ ] okay what should I
do like I guess I have too long before
you get barrels suspect them oh I can't
believe I made it oh god please don't
come in here
[ __ ]
[ __ ] Shane sounds oh [ __ ]
[Music]
Oh
she does head it back
[ __ ] I hit him so much but he still got
him sexy
let's go this way note he he has
returned somehow back from the dead what
am I to make of this
I must document their currents late
night penis right stop it
stop making that knife
actually I'm the one making noise I
think the bro has gone though like we
can continue and [ __ ]
oh this corridor isn't creepy honestly
fine we're in this building right now
saw that freaking monster I would have
put this glass jar on my head and this
key up my [ __ ]
just me I don't know good Oh what is
this
I will not belong my lab I have found
him I can use him I will not fail again
of course he wants
speaking through a cylinder okay so who
should we bring I think we should call
him
Stefano oh come on
it's tie found a look at me I lost I am
Stefano I have the exact same voice as
the skull you talked to earlier
it's called ah all right so far now
let's go you and me buddy
new adventures awaits us this way
are you serious is stupid [ __ ] I'm
sorry I'm not very as much come on
this way PD I can feel it
I think I know what are we gonna do
though we're gonna follow Stefano
it looks like he's riding a horse or
something I am riding a horse you stupid
[ __ ] sorry dude
actually it's not writing in it wait
have they been in here sorry
oh I need a key all right do I have a
key
oh [ __ ] I have a key sorry Stefano I
have to drop you sometimes it's just
it's just part of the rules what do you
have here basement corridor I don't
think we're done in here at all I want
to pick up that acid
so you pretty much show me the wrong way
every single time I am sorry I'm a quite
a week after yeah you have a pretty good
punishment waiting sorry Stefan oh yeah
sorry you should have given him a buddy
here's a sex toy to play with you'll
appreciate this I know it
ah come on now let's venture further
into the doctors as always always the
darkness never never
the [ __ ] that was where we came from and
this is a dead end right no it's not
it's creepy corner how could I forget
how embarrassing
whoa this is the denon what if we walk
in here and then here
whoa what's that the monster yeah what's
Monster barrels hiding me barrels oh I
hate the barrels they're [ __ ]
traitors and there's bears everywhere
I'm screwed I'm definitely Oh
stones steps
how do I look like a stone
hahaha I did not expect okay I'm a stone
I'm a freaking stone
oh man
[Music]
let's go away
I know
take the barrel Oh
I think you liked it it was a parting
gift not a welcoming gift please tell me
he can tell the difference
he's still there isn't he
okay let's take it really slowly
okay all is good always well I've been
in here hello
okay very fine we can move on
I just have to figure out where I'm
supposed to go cuz I kind of forgot
holding room No
this room
nope
No okay here it is I got it we got it no
problem
yeah stop it I know you're really fun
and obnoxious but you don't have to tell
everyone about it okay let's go to the
basement simple lock yeah I'm a genius
[Music]
did did or didn't do it to do that oh
yeah yeah three six days holy [ __ ] some
twenty okay it's worn but sturdy to
break nope let's do this then i weakened
it I'm so smart it's
all right let's keep all go well Oh
oh come on I [ __ ] hate him so much
[Music]
shut up ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh man oh
man I hate him so [ __ ] much
he's not even sexy I've seen her take
the potatoes
tinderbox take the hammer oh [ __ ] he
wants me why am i sweet oh [ __ ]
nothing here
yeah I'm screwed great it's right there
[ __ ] you
[Music]
[ __ ] he's coming over
ah
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] look at this son
of [ __ ] whoa ha ha I was gonna be 360
station okay wait I have a lad a man a
man a lion a lot of animal
yeah said eat it how crap that was not a
good place to throw it
holy Sh he's a [ __ ]
up its have a gate account left there
yeah I've done this before where you see
ah that dude sure likes to splash ah oh
[ __ ] I'm pretty I'm gonna get this off
[Music]
another dead end
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's a lock
than even loud right here nothing
oh there's a door where you see though
there's nothing in here
there's has to be other it is uh uh was
that me or him always over there he's
coming over now is this one of those
useless man oh that right oh [ __ ] I have
the wrong
MLG [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] that was not imitate bad Emily
oh man oh man oh man oh man oh man oh
man oh man oh man oh man [ __ ] he's right
after me escape ah here you go enjoy
your book kind sir
[Music]